[Musik]
künstliche Intelligenz Maschine gegen
mensch das ist unser Thema heute Abend
an diesem Donnerstag um 22 Uhr sind Sie
sehr herzlich begrüßt liebe Zuschauer
ausgerechnet tesla-chef Elon Musk
fordert mit anderen Managern und
Wissenschaftlern eine Pause bei der
Entwicklung künstlicher Intelligenz KI
kann schreiben und sprechen wie ein
Mensch und stellt problemlos Gedichte
Klassenarbeiten Fotos fest was ist noch
echt was gefälscht KI hilft in der
Medizin arbeitet aber längst auch an
Waffensystemen KI ist ein Riesengeschäft
aber auch gefährlicher als die Atombombe
sagt zumindest Elon Musk muss man KI
fürchten oder haben die Europäer die
Deutschen wieder einmal zu viel Angst
und verspielen gerade ihre Zukunft in
die Amerikaner und Chinesen längst
uneinholbar gestartet sind wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
die spd-partei Vorsitzende Saskia esken
die netzaktivistin und linken
Politikerin Anke
isch war Wissenschaftsjournalist
Achim Berg der Präsident des BITKOM
und die Wissenschaftlerin Miriam Meckel
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt alle Gäste noch mal sehr
herzlich Maschinen lernen denken und
machen schon heute ihren Erfindern
Konkurrenz
gefühlt ist es eine Nische für Nerds im
sonnigen Silicon Valley künstliche
Intelligenz eine multimilliarden Dollar
Nische die also keine mehr ist der
Anfang einer Revolution die die
industrielle als Peanuts erscheinen
lässt und Deutschland und Europa sind im
Dämmerschlaf die USA beherrschen 73% des
ki-markts China ist auf Platz 2 und alle
anderen kommen gerade mal auf 12%
. dabei ist KI schon überall in unserem
Alltag
am Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart in einem
Modellprojekt bei Klagen in
dieselskandal
bei der Lufthansa wo Bots sich um
Schadenersatzansprüche kümmern
in Heidelberg als Bürgeramts Mitarbeiter
in der Medizin beim Aufspüren von
Tumoren
aber auch Kriege werden mit KI geführt
ob in berkarabach oder in der Ukraine
und auch Bildung und Journalismus werden
revolutioniert Jet GPT kann bereits
jetzt Mails schreiben oder ganze Bücher
Prognose in wenigen Jahren dann
fehlerfrei
ist bei uns Wissenschaftsjournalist Chat
GPT ist eine dieser neuen Technologien
was war das erste dass sie tschebt haben
und was hat er ausgesprochen
sah also es gab so wissenschaftliche
paper wo man schon merkte okay da kommt
was und dann wurde es geöffnet Ende
letzten Jahres und es war wie so ein
Rausch also ich fing an und dann
probierte man alles ich fragte zum
Beispiel bin ich verheiratet und dann
kam von tschechische fand ich großartig
ja mit mannisha jogisch war auch
Physikerin und beide haben zwei Kinder
was glatt gelogen war aber es war toll
weil man so alles durch soundierte und
ich weiß in den Weihnachtsferien habe
ich mit meinem Schwiegersohn z.B
programmiert mit GPT und das war
großartig also wir haben sogar einen
Artikel verfasst wo man einfach sah da
ist ein gigantisches Potenzial auf der
einen Seite aber auf der anderen Seite
merkt man auch so aber deswegen sind wir
hier deswegen sind wir hier und wir
müssen unbedingt reden über die Risiken
darauf werden wir auf jeden Fall noch
kommen vielleicht noch die Frage auf
welche neuen Möglichkeiten man sich
jetzt mit dieser KI sich eigentlich
freuen kann ich glaube wichtig ist etwas
zu verstehen es ist ein Dammbruch
passiert wir haben ja gerade im Film
einige Beispiele gesehen also KI wurde
auch in der Vergangenheit bei der ein
oder anderen Sache angewendet aber 2017
fing es an und das
entwickelte sich und im letzten Jahr
merkte man dann dass man diese großen
sprachmodelle hat und das ist wirklich
in qualitativer Sprung also da ist eine
völlig neue Qualität entstanden weil der
das was vorher
unterschiedlich war Bild Erkennung oder
Text Erkennung oder Spracherkennung Siri
oder so das kennen wir vielleicht alle
aber jetzt plötzlich gibt es eine KI die
anfängt wirklich alles gleichzeitig zu
können und die immer leistungsfähiger
wird die sich selber optimiert und die
wenn man sich das mal klar macht und die
sogar den Menschen simuliert in einem
ihrer Vorträge erzählen der schnell noch
erwähnen Sie gerne eine virtuelle
Studentin also die digitale Studentin an
einer Universität in China
die Musik machen soll die ist eine
Komponistin oder wird gelabelt als
Komponistin vielleicht gucken wir uns
das mal an
[Musik]
auch dahinter steckt natürlich ranga
Yogeshwar eine Software
ob und wie viel diese Software da
tatsächlich schon kann und tut weiß man
noch nicht aber sind das auch zukünftig
dann die Avatare in die wir irgendwie
uns verlieben sollen mit denen wir
Freundschaften entwickeln also bei dem
bei dem Video ist man sich nicht ganz
sicher weil man in China vielleicht
nicht ganz so viele Daten bekommt aber
ich glaube jeder normale Mensch der
Zukunft und das Bild sieht und sich
einfach mal die Frage stellt diese
Bilder werden wir diese Videos werden
wir in den nächsten Jahren immer mehr
sehen was passiert das also vielleicht
sogar diese Runde ja lässt sich dann
ach die darstellen aber was wird wir
reden ja immer über intellektuelle Jobs
über ja das was passiert im Bereich von
Rechtswissen Eigenschaften oder
Programmierer braucht man weniger was
wird emotional passieren wenn eines
Tages Menschen da sind die diese Avatare
die so menschenähnlich sind mit den
Reden die können das jederzeit diese
Avatare verstehen dank KI auch wie ich
mich fühle wie ich dachte das wird eine
völlig neue Emotion werden und wir haben
überhaupt noch keine Antwort darauf wo
das hinführt wo es hinführt und das
macht es so spannend und los geht's
Miriam Meckel ist bei uns
kommunikationswissenschaftlerinnen und
Unternehmerin sie haben den schönen Satz
gesagt dass unser Leben stärker
verändert werden wird mit KI als durch
das Smartphone und sogar das Internet
und das ist ein großes simultanes
Experimentierfeld ist von dem wir noch
gar nicht wissen wo es hinführt ist dass
das große Mirakel dass man einfach gar
nicht weiß wohin diese riesige
Veränderung gehen wird naja wir sind im
Grunde ja gerade mitten in diesem
live-experiment drin wir haben
angefangen Ranka logisch hat gesagt das
war Ende des letzten Jahres als mit Jet
GPT diese Anwendung auf den Markt
gekommen ist und ich würde wirklich
sagen das war der iPhone Moment der
künstlichen Intelligenz weil in dem
Moment plötzlich der anwenden die
Anwendungsebene in eine breite Masse
gekommen ist ne was vorher im
Industriebereich eine Rolle gespielt hat
in der Medizin in Expertensystem eine
Rolle gespielt hat war plötzlich für
jeden handhabar man konnte zu Hause
sitzen und konnte mit einer künstlichen
Intelligenz anfangen Gespräche zu führen
Sie Texte schreiben lassen und also hier
Dinge und das ist natürlich eine
Veränderung in unserer kulturellen
Evolution bei der wir gerade mitten in
einem Selbstexperiment sind man könnte
sagen als Menschheit und wir wissen
nicht was daraus rauskommen wird und das
ist ja immer der Punkt wir wenn wir
darüber diskutieren reden wir ganz oft
darüber was macht die Technologie die
macht eigentlich nichts sondern wir
erfinden sie erstens und zweitens
benutzen wir Sie und alles was KI macht
entsteht dadurch dass wir mit ihr
interagieren und jetzt für sie füttern
dass wir sie füttern und dass wir dass
wir auf sie reagieren auch die Frage wie
reagieren wir emotional beispielsweise
auf digitale Menschen die die junge
Sängerin die chinesische ist ja nur ein
Beispiel es gibt tatsächlich eine einen
ganzen Industriezweig der sogenannte
digitale Menschen produziert das ist
jetzt eine schlechte Nachricht aber
solche die beispielsweise auch Sendungen
moderieren können was für China längste
passiert jederzeit bitte alles mögliche
andere die die sämtliche
Kommunikationsleistungen bieten können
und die sind so perfekt unperfekt
gemacht ich habe sie mir angeschaut in
verschiedenen Dimensionen dass man
wirklich nicht weiß wie soll ich das
unterscheiden und das heißt wie
reagieren relativ ähnlich wie wir auf
reale Menschen reagieren und das ist ein
großes Experiment unsere
selbstverhaltensweisen verändern wird
und wir sind Anke dummscheitberg für die
Linke im Deutschen Bundestag und
netzaktivistin natürlich bei der Frage
wo auch ihre Faszinationen war bevor wir
jetzt dann auch darüber reden natürlich
wo die großen Gefahren liegen was finden
sie faszinierend an dem was dazu künftig
möglich sein wird oder jetzt einfach die
Fantasie anregt das sind ja ganz viele
Barrieren weggefallen also als Mensch
mit einer Maschine zu reden erfordert
jetzt keinerlei spezielle Kompetenzen
mehr niemand muss mehr programmieren
lernen
bestimmte Steuerung lernen man kann
einfach ganz normal mit der Maschine
reden und die reagiert darauf und man
kann auch ganz viele Dinge tun die
eigentlich große Qualifikationen oder
Talente erfordern ja im Design Bereich
zum Beispiel oder zum Beispiel auch das
Programmieren und das braucht man in dem
Maße ja auch nicht mehr jetzt jetzt
braucht man andere Kompetenzen ja wie
schreibt man einen klugen prompt also so
ein Befehl einen kleinen Auftrag
an die KI und das ist natürlich total
faszinierend also auch Menschen die es
zum Beispiel schwer haben sich
hochgestochen auszudrücken oder die eine
Rechtschreibschwäche haben oder die
nicht so gut Englisch können mit einem
einzigen Knopfdruck können die einen roh
geschriebenen Text in gestochenes
Hochdeutsch formulieren können sogar
sagen dass es besonders wissenschaftlich
klingen dann wird es das auch tun aber
da sind wir dann schon ja wenn es dann
anfängt Dinge zu erfinden sondern
vielleicht schon beim nächsten Thema und
dann sagen sie den Satz dass wir im
Grunde damit ein Waffenlager aufgemacht
haben und den Menschen aber bitten nicht
zu schießen das heißt was
naja es ist schon ein sehr sehr
mächtiges Werkzeug das also auch nicht
ein Werkzeug ist sondern ganz viele
verschiedene Werkzeuge dass ich für
unendlich viele verschiedene Dinge
einsetzen kann viele davon sind
großartig also Hautkrebs besser zu
erkennen und früher zu erkennen ist
großartig und rettet Menschen leben ich
kann aber genauso gut ganz andere Dinge
die gefährlich sind damit tun und
im Moment lassen wir ein Waffenarsenal
praktisch mit einem offenen Scheunentor
stehen und jeder kann hingehen und sich
bedienen und wir hoffen irgendwie dass
keiner böse tut also wir sind was die
Regulierung angeht noch nicht darauf
eingestellt aber auch überhaupt was die
Kompetenzen der Menschen angeht wie
reagiert man auf bestimmte Dinge die
passieren das ist ja schon angesprochen
worden ja wie geht man es ist zum
Beispiel mit dem Thema falschen
Informationen um wenn man hervorragend
Dinge fälschen kann wir sind nicht
darauf vorbereitet als Gesellschaft und
das betrifft die Politik die
Entscheidungen treffen muss zu
regulierungs betrifft aber auch die ganz
normale Bevölkerung und da sind wir noch
nicht bei der Veränderung von
Arbeitsplätzen auf die wir auch nicht
entsprechend vorbereitet sind darüber
versuchen wir heute zu reden saskia
esken ist bei uns die
SPD-Parteivorsitzende und gelernte
Informatikerin Frau esken und natürlich
erinnern wir dass wir schon mal eine
Krise hatten in der wir so wahnsinnig
auf
IT und auch auf KI gehofft haben nämlich
die corona-krise und dann merkten dass
die deutsche Politik damit Faxgeräten
gegensteuern wollte also die ganz banale
Frage natürlich ist es ihre politische
Aufgabe und das werden sie uns auch in
dieser Sendung sagen tapfer nach
Regularien und eben Mechanismen zu
schauen um eine solche große Waffe
einzuheben glauben Sie wirklich dass das
gelingen wird naja also mit Faxgeräten
arbeitet die die Gesundheitsverwaltung
an der Stelle und das ist auch
tatsächlich ein Problem und es fehlen
uns die Datengrundlagen um klug mit
solchen Situationen umzugehen das stimmt
der Zugriff auch auf die entsprechenden
Datengrundlagen die Qualität der
Datengrundlagen und deswegen sind wir da
auch ein Stück weit hinterher auf der
anderen Seite will ich ganz deutlich
sagen also die Sache mit der Informatik
ist wirklich schon sehr sehr viele Jahre
her aber auch da damals vor 35 und 40
Jahren hat natürlich die Informatik
schon über neuronale Netze und
künstliche Intelligenz in
Anführungsstrichen haben wir damals
schon gesagt und haben gesagt es ist
eine Anmaßung dass wir an die
Intelligenz insbesondere des Menschen
herankommen aber insgesamt an
Intelligenzleistung mit diesen
künstlichen neuronalen Netzen und ich
glaube auch dass wir heute noch weit
davon entfernt sind von all dem was hier
beschrieben wird ich erinnere an die
onkette-kommission die wir zusammen
hatten wo am Anke Domstadt Birk und ich
teilnehmen durften mit 19 ExpertInnen
Experten die zunächst mal mit uns
geklärt haben worum geht es ja
eigentlich was müssen wir regulieren und
die haben ganz klar gesagt Leute um
iRobot geht's noch lange nicht das ist
nicht unser Thema sondern unser Thema
sind Algorithmen rasierte Entscheidungen
die wir zu regulieren haben wo wir zu
klären haben wo beginnt die
Diskriminierung wo beginnt der Vorteil
und was ist unsere Aufgabe als Menschen
und als Politik natürlich die Richtung
vorzugeben die Ziele klarzulegen die
Rahmenbedingungen und natürlich auch die
Grenzen aufzuzeigen und das wird auch
weiterhin unsere Aufgabe sein Europa ist
ähm in dieser also die Europäische Union
in dieser Frage wesentlich weiter als
die USA mit dem EA Act kommen wir noch
richtig seit 21 wird daran gearbeitet
wir wollen unbedingt Achim Berg begrüßen
Präsident des Bitcoin des
digitalverbandes wir haben ich habe zu
Beginn Elon Musk erwähnt das ist ein
manischer Internet Guru der um eine
Pause gebeten hat und eigentlich nicht
dafür berühmt ist dass er irgendwie den
Fortschritt behindern möchte also da
reden wir offensichtlich eben auch über
Wissenschaftler und Unternehmer die
jetzt in der großen Sorge sind dass man
diese Regularien das Einlegen nicht mehr
schaffen könnte
also da kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen
das ist so ein deutscher bürokratischer
Bedenkenträger oder so ne jetzt ist er
ist das glatte Gegenteil weil da haben
sie sich darüber
gewunderte Idee mal drüber nachzudenken
aber wenn man dann tiefer reingeht gibt
es gibt wesentlich größere Probleme auf
der Einheit zum Beispiel wie können wir
eigentlich Intelligenz und so eine
chetschebt trainieren das sind Themen
die hat er gar nicht erwähnt das sind
ganz wichtig dass da wirklich
Informationen rauskommt dann habe ich
mir die Frage gestellt was machen
eigentlich die Tausende von Entwicklern
mit den halbes Jahr nichts tun gucken
die aus dem Fenster das ist doch Theorie
das funktioniert doch sowieso nicht nach
Leben nicht und dann wirklich die Frage
stellt es gibt wirklich schon genügend
Dinge auch schon Regularien es gibt die
Uhrzeit OECD die hat über 400
Fallbeispiele gehabt es gibt die ich war
die Amerikaner die den ich glaube den
denen die jetzt nicht oder so ähnlich
die haben auch schon über 70 Seiten
geschrieben zu Regulierung ich habe das
dumpfe Gefühl dass er nicht ganz ohne
eigenes gehandelt hat und wenn man genau
schaut wieder angeschaut hat dann war
das ist das glaube ich sehr viel
eigennutziger als gerade denken ich bin
auch im Nachhinein finde ich es ist ein
Prag und nicht mehr nicht also man weiß
Menschen mir natürlich man kann
nachlesen dass Elon Musk eben ähnlich
wie Microsoft
GPT beteiligt ist und es mit finanziert
und dann sagen sie dann ist es eine
PR-Aktion oder er ist ausgegangen ist
Microsoft reingegangen ist das ist das
führt ja ein bisschen in diese Richtung
also muss man völlig aufpassen dass ich
da nicht instrumentalisieren lässt wobei
in der grundsache ja eigentlich recht
hat also man muss die Teams ja gerade
die muss man muss die Themen wirklich
anfangen gerade also einfache Sachen
wenn ich jetzt mehr Briefe schreiben
dass sowas das muss nicht reguliert
werden aber es gibt mit Sicherheit
Bereiche wenn ich hin möchten also z.B
was in China passiert dass man da
irgendwo nach Sozialpunkten die die die
die die Einwohner im Prinzip das darf
bei uns nicht passieren das sind faire
Dinge die müssen fast die müssen auch
wirklich geregelt werden der ist auch
die Politik gefragt aber das von einem
anderen Mast zu gehören das war schon
ein bisschen besonders
an der Stelle ist glaube ich wenn man
das Papier genau liest geht's ja darum
dass man sagen
sagt man und ich habe keine Interessen
an der Stelle aber es geht darum zu
sagen liebe Leute wir müssen den Moment
warten bevor wir noch größere Modelle
trainieren
im Papier steht ganz klar drin es geht
nicht darum weiterzuforschen aber es
gibt darum und das ist glaube ich schon
wichtig denn dieses Papier hat nicht nur
allen Musk den kennen alle Medien
schaffenden aber über 1.000 Spezialisten
die in der Branche arbeiten die sagen
alle wir verstehen diese Systeme nicht
und man muss sich die gesamts klar
machen wir haben eine Blackbox das ist
nicht programmieren so wie zur Zeiten wo
Frau es genug programmiert hat da hat
man Code geschrieben hier ist es eine
Blackbox die Eigenschaften hat die
selber die Wissenschaftler überraschen
aber also die Fachleute sagen selber wir
verstehen nicht so richtig was da
passiert ist ich glaube da für den
iplikationen die das mit sich bringt zu
sagen Leute wir müssen momentan darüber
nach denken wir haben hier etwas und
verstehen es nicht und es hat irrsinnige
Konsequenzen finde ich persönlich
wünschenswert die Diskussion muss da
sein richtig aber jetzt bleibt wirklich
eine Frage dazu sollte zu seiner sich
die Welt auf einen Standard einigt was
ich total bezweifle in den sechs Monaten
umsetzt alles sehr theoretisch also es
hört sich alles sehr theoretisch an
nochmal die Grundaussage ist nicht die
falsche aber der hat noch mit Chat gbt
3.5 und 30 für die gleichen Fragen warum
jetzt auf einmal 40 mehr mich einfach
nur gegen den Brief nicht gegen die
Aussage den Brief selber aber der war
schon etwas war schon es geht ohne
Insider der Rest zu wirken darum dass
diese Modelle immer größer werden ja der
Unterschied zwischen gpt3 was zu
Weihnachten ja offen gelegt wurde und
den neuen Modellen ist dass die sehr
viel größer sind und das Interessante
ist dass sie jetzt anfangen Züge zu
haben okay größer im Sinne von die
Parameter in dem großen Netzwerk man
muss sich vorstellen das ist im Grunde
genommen so eine Art neuronales so
ähnlich wie das Gehirn das kann man
simulieren mit ganz viel Rechenpower
also das sind die die schärfsten größten
Rechner die da sind also allein der
Stromverbrauch ja der geht in die
Gigawatt und diese Systeme werden
sozusagen mit datenprogrammiert und man
versteht nicht so richtig was sie machen
man versteht auch nicht wie sie intern
denken und das ist an irgendeiner Stelle
etwas
gut aufpassen
menschliche Eigenschaften ich hätte
ihnen vielleicht vor ein paar Jahren
sofort Recht gegeben gesagt ja die
denken nicht inzwischen sage ich ganz
ehrlich wenn man sich tiefer damit
befasst kommen Fragen auf ob das so
wirklich stimmt also ob wir nicht hier
Systeme haben die eine andere Form von
denken haben denn alle Tests ich meine
das ist einfach nicht verstanden
was kann der Mensch was kann die
Maschine und wenn man das vergleicht
kann man das nicht mehr unterscheiden
ich glaube es ist nur eine Frage der
Definition was denken ist also ja genau
im Grunde genommen und das müssten wir
vielleicht einmal ganz deutlich sagen
ist ist ein ein solches Tool ein solches
System ja nichts anderes als ein
unfassbar kraftvolles vorhersagetool
also auszurechnen jetzt im Beispiel für
jet-pt welches Wort kommt mit welcher
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach diesem Wort
macht das System setzt das System in die
Lage einen Text zu produzieren der wie
ein menschlicher Text für uns überzeugen
klingt das heißt
Statistik ja einen einen
wahrscheinlichkeitsausrechnungsmodell
und wenn wir das Gefühl haben diese
Modelle denken und natürlich gibt es die
Diskussion ich finde es auch richtig sie
zu führen aber dann ist das wieder ein
Thema wir haben das Thema weil wir
natürlich auch nur in unserer
Wahrnehmung was ist menschliches Denken
dieses menschliche Denken beschreiben
können und wenn ein System anders
operiert anders vorgeht wie ich das
gerade beschrieben habe dann kann das
trotzdem eine reine
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung sein aber
für uns sind die produzierten Ergebnisse
so dass man denkt das ist denken und es
gibt ja eine Reihe von Beispielen google
hat der letzten Sommer die Situation
dass ein Programmierer mit einem solchen
großen Sprachmodell interagiert hat das
ist ein 40 Seiten Manuskript über
Stunden haben die miteinander gesprochen
er hat gesprochen das System hat
reagiert und dann hat der Programmierer
gesagt dieses System hat ein Bewusstsein
hat eine riesen Diskussion ausgelöst der
arbeitet inzwischen nicht mehr bei
Google weil die sich mit Händen und
Füßen dagegen gewehrt haben dass man
sagt ein solches System denkt und hat
ein Bewusstsein und den Eindruck können
wir bekommen ich würde trotzdem ganz
ganz vorsichtig mit dieser Aussage sein
weil ich glaube wir wir geraten da
wirklich auf dem gefährlichen Pfad den
wir selber liegen gut wir kommen gleich
noch mal zu den Arbeitsplätzen und zu
den Veränderungen in unserem Leben durch
diese neue System ich wollte Achim Berg
noch einmal nach Microsoft Fragen und
auch nachdem was ich vorhin schon mal
falsch gesagt habe aber auch der
Finanzierung der privaten Finanzierung
dieser
die neuen Technologie also dieser
künstlichen Intelligenz bei ces ist eben
unter anderem Microsoft finanziert das
war eines der vielen Unternehmen für die
Sie gearbeitet haben dabei würden Sie
denn denken dass ich
ehemalige Arbeitgeber für sowas wie
Verbraucherschutz interessiert also
haben diese Unternehmen
haben diese Unternehmen ein Interesse
daran oder sind die jetzt einfach alle
so enthusiasmiert und wollen den anderen
Konkurrenten irgendwie schnell vom Markt
hauen dass man über sowas am liebsten
gar nicht nachdenkt grundsätzlich
Microsoft gelungen im November letzten
Jahres ist die auf dem Markt gebracht
haben das haben mit Sicherheit eine
tolle Sache es werden aber auch andere
kommen also google wird kommen und viele
andere auch die Chinesen werden kommen
die werden alle mit diesen Tools kommen
ist auch gut so es gibt auch
konkurrierende Tools und die werden auch
ziemlich genau das gleiche können denken
ich glaube das wird keiner gewinnen aber
was was ganz gut ist Microsoft einen
großen Vorteil Microsoft diese
Intelligenz in ihre Systeme bringen also
ihre Worte
System das heißt ich werde irgendwann
hingehen und werde sagen ich müsste
eigentlich dem Anker jogisch bei einem
mal eine Mail beantworten und der
Kräutern in meinem ganzen meine ganzen
Inbox und guckt was war alles
kommuniziert haben und schlägt mir dann
eine E-Mail vor das sind so Themen das
ist auch eine schöne Helferlein also er
sucht dann genau raus was haben wir
etwas darüber gesprochen ich sag dann
das haben wir besprochen und dann kann
man Vorschlag also die Themen das ist im
Prinzip die Idee von Microsoft also
microsoft wird das dann in die
kommerziellen Systeme integrieren und
Microsoft wird noch was machen ist ein
großes Problem ist die Daten auch im
Prinzip
einsperren also das Firmen ihre Daten
nicht frei in die Welt blasen sondern
dass sie nur in ihre eigene Instanz
arbeiten das werden die machen das ist
also kommerzielle interessant im Moment
ist es für Microsoft ein teures Spiel
danke hat gesagt die Rechenleistung ist
unglaublich hoch das muss ich als
kommerzialisieren das wird aber mit
Sicherheit ein Modell sein was ich
durchgerechnet haben
genau muss man kein Mitleid haben wir
sind beim Datenschutz beim Thema
Datenschutz ist es so dass bestimmen wir
doch also gerade die naturkommission sie
hatten schon den dieses Jahr kommen soll
also wir müssen schon bestimmen was man
damit kann was man nicht kann microsoft
versucht der Chech über die sehr
freundlich zu halten das haben sie auch
zugegeben also der immer ganz
freundliche Antworten ganz nette
Antworten und dann freut sich richtig
und fühlt sich auch gebuchtselt aber ob
das jetzt in den und der nächste Punkt
ist ja es ist ja eigentlich nach
amerikanischer Logik das heißt das Thema
was weiß ich jetzt also alle die Themen
die sind in amerikanischen
amerikanischen Logik aber nicht in
europäischen Logik also weißt du jetzt
irgendwelche sexuellen Themen sind oder
andere Sachen die werden herausgefiltert
das haben wir nicht in der Hand das
macht das machen halt die Amerikaner das
ist auch okay das müssen aber es ist
halt eine andere eine andere Kulturkreis
hat wir reden nicht zum ersten Mal über
die großen fünf also auch das ist eben
eine Industrie die vor allen Dingen in
den USA zu Hause ist wo die Europäer bis
heute an keiner Stelle groß etwas zu
melden haben ist daran noch etwas zu
ändern also wir sind wie immer sehr spät
und es gibt ja eine europäische
Vereinigung für große sprachmodelle also
genau dieses Thema über die wir reden
Leim Liam das ist wenn man ein bisschen
zynisch sein will ein Anagramm für das
englische lame lahm und das sind wir an
dem Punkt weil es gibt jetzt eine
Machbarkeitsstudie über die Frage ob wir
in Europa nicht diese Modelle entwickeln
sollten und könnten und an der Stelle
denke ich halt es hilft wenn man wenn
man selber in der Praxis der Entwicklung
drin ist auch die Fragen von Datenschutz
von Transparenz der Modelle von
regulierungsnotwendigkeiten zu
entscheiden da sind wir spät und der
Wettbewerb der Achim Berg eben
beschrieben hat wird mehr oder minder
ohne uns stattfinden wir haben
Unternehmen wie alles Alpha in
Deutschland die das Entwickeln das will
ich nicht unter den den Tisch kehren
aber es ist im Vergleich zu dem was in
den USA passiert ein ein echter Nachteil
China
eigenes Modell die Chinesen haben gerade
gesagt dass sie jetzt anfangen werden
diese Modelle zu regulieren die also
sozusagen zertifiziert werden müssen und
die entsprechen zwischen dem
sozialistischen Geist ihre Ergebnisse
produzieren müssen so ähnlich lautet das
da muss man sagen da reden wir über
kulturelle Differenzen die nicht
funktionieren werden das heißt für
unsere Welt werden diese Modelle nicht
relevant sein umgekehrt vermutlich auch
nicht aber was in USA passiert da spielt
die Musik unter den großen die wir jetzt
hier das gefunden sie haben noch letztes
Jahr gesagt diese fünf großen Konzerne
diese digitalkonzerne sind zu groß und
sie haben die Diskussion sie zu
zerschlagen begrüßt das haben die
US-Amerikaner in ihrer Historie schon
mal gemacht würden sie das heute immer
noch sein also der Unterschied zwischen
den den deutschen den europäischen
Entwicklern und den US-amerikanischen
ist tatsächlich das Geld nicht die
mangelnden Fähigkeiten sondern das
machen sie die Geld ist da rein
investiert wird in diese in diese Arbeit
und immer also meinen ehemaliger
Arbeitgeber wo ich dann tatsächlich auch
programmiert habe die machen seit
Jahrzehnten in diesen Themen ist auch
ein amerikanischer ähm hat der
Hersteller und und die haben aber keine
keine Monet ein Interessen darin sondern
wissenschaftliches und
wissenschaftliches Interesse und am Ende
kommt es darauf an dass wir in Europa
uns auch zusammentun und uns stark
machen in der Entwicklung in der in der
in der in der gemeinsamen Regulierung in
der gemeinsamen Weiterentwicklung die
Frage ist bei den großen Konzernen
erstens das Monopol und zweitens die das
Zusammenspiel von unterschiedlichen
Fähigkeiten bei google hat man immer
gesagt eben nicht nur die Suchmaschine
sondern das große Unternehmen er hat
eben nicht nur die Suchmaschine sondern
eben auch Youtube und in der in der
Suchmaschine drin eigene Interessen
eigene Ergebnisse die dann oben
platziert werden gerankt werden eigene
Interessen im Verkaufen von Werbung und
die sich die sich gegenseitig so
verstärken dass eben da eine Kontrolle
von unserer Seite kaum mehr möglich ist
und deswegen er hat man gesagt vor allem
muss man die einzelnen Unternehmensteile
sehr schlagen aber Monopole das wissen
wir auch sind am Ende
innovationsfeindlich und auch dagegen
müssen wir vorgehen wir verweisen immer
wie ich gehe hier auch gleich noch mal
auf die rechte Seite des Tisches aber
vielleicht ziehen wir noch mal rein
worüber wir andeutungsweise schon
Sprachen es wird bei den Gefahren und
Risiken ja immer auf eben China und
Russland auch verwiesen gegebenenfalls
haben wir sie auch weil wir feststellen
dass diese neue Technik verblüffend
Lügen und fälschen kann
zwei Fotos aber nur einen der beiden
gibt es wirklich der andere erstellt von
künstlicher Intelligenz durch
Texteingabe einem sogenannten prompt
mit journey heißt der ki-bildgenerator
und er liefert was
Verschwörungstheoretikern das Herz höher
schlagen lässt
ob Beweise für die Mondlandung die es ja
nie gab die Verhaftung von Donald Trump
noch vor Verlesung der Anklage
oder der Papst im luxustaunenmantel auch
diese vier Spaziergänger rein künstlich
ihn gibt es schon und Davids kniffliger
denn Boris Johnson traut man alles zu
nur ein Zoom auf die Hände verrät noch
das ist nicht der expremiere es ist KI
da sind wir beim Thema Anke
domscheitberg was passiert in einer Welt
was passiert in unserem Land wenn wir
keiner Information keinem Bild keinem
Stück Filmen mehr so trauen können wie
wir sonst eigentlich einem Bild immer
den Vorzug gegeben haben wenn wir etwas
bewerten mussten ganz genau wissen wir
das ja gar nicht aber die Situation
trifft uns natürlich in einer Situation
wo wir sowieso schon ein gesteigertes
Misstrauen haben in demokratische
Prozesse in Medien in bestimmte
Institutionen wo Verschwörungstheorien
blühen und leider sehr viele Anhänger in
den finden und in so eine Zeit hinein
kommt jetzt ein mächtiges Medium dass
uns ermöglicht perfekt zu lügen und das
mit Beweisen zu unterlegen und
Forschung hat inzwischen ja auch
nachgewiesen was Informationen für
Menschen glaubwürdiger gemacht das ist
z.B eine Seite eine besonders eloquente
davidung also ohne die komischen
Ausdrücke und die Schreibfehler wie man
das ja so früher mal so kann das kommt
jetzt also in perfekt und sieht
wissenschaftlich aus mit pseudoquellen
und allem drum und dran und das zweite
ist wenn wir das noch mit unseren
eigenen Augen sehen und mit unseren
eigenen Ohren hören können wird es auch
glaubwürdiger aber es sind halt gefakte
Bilder gefakte Videos gefakte Audios in
perfekt wir hören also ein gefälschtes
Obama Video mit der echten Obama Stimme
frei erfundenes Zeug erzählen und das
ist natürlich hochgradig gefährlich weil
wir wissen auch heute also das hat ja
früher schon gegeben nur heute mit dem
Unterschied skaliert es ja ganz anders
also jetzt kann ich das massenhaft
machen und so sogenannte deepakes also
perfekte Fälschungen von Videos oder
Fotos zu machen da dazu gehört es schon
eine gewisse technische Kompetenz
gewisse Werkzeuge zu haben
könnte das kann wirklich jeder Depp im
Keller oder im Wohnzimmer machen das
erfordert nichts mehr eigentlich und ich
kann das ganz leicht machen ich kann es
ohne Vorkenntnisse machen und dadurch
kann ich es massenhaft machen und wir
können am Ende nicht mehr gut
unterscheiden was ist eigentlich war und
was ist nicht wahr und was wir auch
mitbekommen haben ist das die KI die ja
auch selber halluziniert und wirklich
herbei Dinge herbeifantasiert
dass sie diesen Bullshit Output für sich
selber benutzt und daraus lernt und das
ist Inzest eine
informationsverschmutzung
wo am Ende man eigentlich also ich mir
fällt es sehr schwer mir vorzustellen
wohin das eigentlich führt wenn am Ende
selbst wissenschaftliche Artikel nicht
mehr plausibel sind ja früher haben wir
so da haben ja Ministerinnen ihre Jobs
verloren oder ihre Posten weil man in
den Doktorarbeiten irgendwelche
Fälschungen nachgewiesen hat weil man
hat die Quelle nicht zitiert aus einem
anderen Buch gefunden wie will ich dann
was finden was
wo ich jedes Mal ein anderer Output
kommt wenn in einer eingibt ich kann das
gar nicht mehr beweisen Saskia esken
wollte nicht so richtig antworten auf
die Frage nach der Zerschlagung noch mal
ist das auch eine Möglichkeit in ihren
Augen oder sagen Sie wir werden das
schaffen wir werden schaffen diese
Regularien diese risikoeinstufungen zu
formulieren und werden das hier
wenigstens in Europa hinbekommen also
die aktuellen digitalen Monopole sehe
ich schon als Bedrohung auch für die
Demokratie jetzt haben wir noch mal ein
exponentielles macht Wachstum dass ich
wieder konzentriert auf die gleichen
wenigen Leute an deren Spitze einzelne
Milliardäre stehen die im Prinzip die
Zukunft der Welt mitbestimmen und über
künstliche Intelligenz kann ich sehr
viel Macht haben auf das Leben von sehr
vielen Menschen das in die Hände einiger
weniger einzelne Personen zu geben ist
per se gefährlich also das dürfen wir
uns gar nicht gefallen lassen
wir können ja nicht diese Unternehmen
zerschlagen das können die US-Amerikaner
machen und ich fände es auch gut so was
wir aber können und da würde ich ein
bisschen widersprechen ich glaube nicht
dazu ist abgefahren für Europa der ist
noch nicht abgefahren aber es besteht
höchste Handlungsbedarf und wir brauchen
eine ethische
gemeinwohlorientierte öffentlich
finanziert und eben nicht irgendwelchen
kommerziellen Interessen und einzelnen
Konzernen
unterlegene Alternative dazu wir
brauchen eigentlich übrigens mal gedacht
also dieses das heißt
das was ich in diesem Brief vermisst
habe ist eine Forderung wenn man schon
nicht versteht wie es funktioniert dann
müssen wir es doch wirklich öffnen wir
müssen das transparent machen wir müssen
es nachvollziehbar machen wir müssen
allen wissenschaftlernen einen Einblick
ermöglichen Transparenz fragen wir
gleich Sekunde war muss uns erklären
warum nun auch der große KI-Forscher 45
Jahre hat er geforscht in wirklich stört
Russell heute in einem Interview sagt
wir können uns kein Tschernobyl für KI
leisten wir sind an einem Scheidepunkt
der Branche und der Menschheit
das ist im Grunde genommen eine
Perspektive und das klingt auf den
ersten Blick wenn man das heute Abend
hört denkt man oh Gott übertreiben die
und ich sage vielleicht nicht weil wir
einfach zwei Schritte weiter denken
müssen wir reden ja jetzt zum Beispiel
von Risiken die wir heute sehen ich
spule einfach mal kurz die Zeit zurück
als die sozialen Netzwerke anfingen war
es für jeden von uns großartig zu sagen
connecting the world miteinander
verbinden neue Freunde finden das war
sozusagen die Basis und niemand hätte
einen Ernstes gesagt oh das ist nicht
gut
heute wissen wir dass diese sozialen
Netzwerke auf der einen Seite großartig
sind weil tatsächlich Familien wunderbar
miteinander zum Beispiel kommunizieren
können aber wir sehen ein Riesenproblem
von Sucht von Fake News von einer
Polarisierung die in der Politik ja die
die Gesellschaften auseinandertreibt von
bei jungen Leute zum Beispiel Depression
die zunimmt von Verhaltensänderung das
heißt wir haben ein System geschaffen
und wussten nicht welche Risiken da sind
und jetzt sind sie da und das
Interessante ist diese Risiken haben wir
nicht mehr oder können wir nicht mehr
zurückfahren das heißt heute merken wir
die Polarisierung in der Gesellschaft
ist da ich meine in diesem Studio saßen
wir zu Corona und da hat man sehr schön
gemerkt was eigentlich so die daraus
resultierenden Folgen sind und jetzt
stehen wir wieder vor einer Situation
ich glaube das ist das was man bei und
klugen Menschen auf sie die sagen hey
wir dürfen nicht noch einmal den Fehler
machen wir müssen einen Moment lang
innehalten und darüber nachdenken denn
wie werden Wahlen aussehen wenn
diese intelligenten boards in der Lage
sind einen so subtil zu manipulieren das
am Ende tatsächlich politische
Ergebnisse
programmiert werden können also habe
Geld und du kannst dir deine
Gesellschaft nicht mehr Millionen Rubel
oder Dollar ausgeben wie die russische
Regierung wenn sie amerikanische Wahlen
finden sondern im Grunde kann das jeder
machen also wir haben eine Achim Berg
wird schon unruhig ich wollte einmal
schnell Frau Merkel fragen wir haben
eben eigentlich eine eine Waffe für alle
auch die Demokratie zu zerstören also
ich würde das gerne an einer Stelle
auseinanderhalten ich glaube ja Waffe
für alle ist richtig weil es halt
zugänglich ist und dass das haben wir ja
diskutiert ich glaube nur wenn wir mit
solchen Möglichkeiten jetzt operieren
wie Waffen dann dann sind wir ganz
schnell wirklich auf dem auf dem
falschen Pfad was wir aus der
technologiegeschichte wissen ist dass
wir kurzfristige
folgenüberschätzen und langfristige
Folgen unterschätzen und dass wir
deshalb in der Regel falsch vorgehen
damit umzugehen ich will mal ein anderes
Beispiel nehmen weil weil das ja auch im
in der Ankündigung der Sendung eine
Rolle gespielt hat Atomenergie wir haben
bei der Atomenergie durch verschiedene
Ereignisse die wir historisch alle
erinnern irgendwann die Bremse gezogen
übrigens auch die Bremse an vielen
Stellen der Forschung und wir sehen
heute dass wir in einer Situation sind
ohne dass ich jetzt der Kernenergie hier
das Wort reden will ja dass das ist
sicher ein differenziertes Thema aber
hätten wir das nicht so gemacht auch in
Deutschland nicht so gemacht würden wir
jetzt in einer Situation die eine ganz
andere Anforderung an und stellt in der
Lage sein damit anders umzugehen wir
wissen vielleicht sehr viel mehr über
Kern Fusion als über Kernspaltung und
könnten vielleicht da ganz andere Wege
gehen hätten wir sehr viel günstigere
sehr viel ökologische und sehr viel
sicherere Energie aus dieser Quelle ein
eine These und das was ich damit sagen
will ist wir schütten jetzt alle Kinder
mit einem Bart aus wenn wir sagen das
ist eine Waffe und die können wir nur
wenn wir sie jetzt stoppen irgendwie in
den Griff bekommen ich glaube das ist
absolut notwendig ist diese Themen
durchzudeklinieren das ist Transparenz
braucht auch über die Frage mit welchen
Daten werden diese Systeme und wir sind
noch in einem kinderstadium im Grunde
genommen wir füttern sie als Mensch der
also diese Maschinen werden ja noch das
können wir auch noch erzählen von
digitalarbeitern in dem digitalen Süden
irgendwie beigebracht für einen
Hungerlohn also wir Menschen füttern
diese Maschinen sozusagen noch mit
unseren Daten und malen uns jetzt
welchen Zustand aus wenn Sie das
kinderstadium verlassen hat naja es
kommt eben darauf an was wir jetzt tun
aber die eine Variante ist zu sagen wir
müssen brauchen eine Moderatorin wir
müssen alles stoppen und das ist eine
Waffe die andere Variante ist wirklich
konstruktiv und mit dem Geld was dafür
notwendig ist nicht nur auf europäische
auf deutscher Ebene da reinzugehen zu
sagen wir wollen wirklich dafür Sorge
tragen was wir mit Voraussetzungen von
Transparenz mit bestimmten Prüfverfahren
mit Audits wie das ja in Europa in der
in der KI in work auch festgelegte sind
so weiter dafür sorgen dass die
Implementierung Schritt für Schritt so
geht dass wir es wirklich verfolgen
können und überprüfen können und dass
wir dann die guten Möglichkeiten nutzen
können ohne dass uns die Demokratie um
die Ohren werden sie glauben dass
amerikanische Firmen tatsächlich an
diese Transparenz ein Interesse haben
dass sie ein also werden die ihre
Algorithmen offenlegen werden Sie sagen
wie ihre wichtigsten
maschinenarbeiten also das kann ich mir
so nicht vorstellen aber ich kann euch
durchaus vorstellen was sehr viel
wichtiger ist wir werden die gefüttert
nach welchen Regeln die gefüttert und
das ist entscheidende das war jetzt
wirklich verstehen deshalb ist die
Diskussion die rutscht mir sogar die
falsche Richtung dass wir jetzt sagen
wir hätten auch 120 Jahren hier gesessen
das Auto kann man niemals zulassen weil
der sterben tausende von Menschen hätten
auch nicht gemacht bei Innovation muss
man glaube ich mit offenen Augen
rangehen das habt ihr alle gesagt hier
wir müssen aber auch gerade versuchen
in den Prozessen uns die Regeln zu
schaffen wir wissen doch gar nicht was
kommt wir wissen doch gar nicht was wir
da alles können also jetzt nicht stoppen
und Sagen um Gottes Willen ja irgendwie
nur nicht irgendjemanden ne noch mal
also da werden ja jetzt tatsächlich auch
richtige Gurus der branchezitiert die
waren nämlich was sagen darf ich glaube
es gibt ein wesentlichen Unterschied zum
Beispiel zu dem Bild der Kernenergie und
das ist wir haben es hier mit einer
Technologie zu tun die erstmalig in der
Lage ist sich selber zu verstärken das
heißt
nein nein nein nein
diese Art nein nein nein
die die sozialen Medien so gefährlich
machen nein es geht hier ein Moment es
geht hier darum dass sie ein System
haben was sich selber optimiert diese
Qualität und zwar selber
diese Qualität hat es vorher nicht
gegeben und das führt zu einer völlig
anderen Bewertung muss dazu führen weil
wir hier eine Selbstverstärkung haben
also ich bin ein Freund von der Technik
bestimmt aber diese Qualität ist für
dich natürlich wir lernen der
Algorithmen sind nicht neu also
offensichtlich lernen der Algorithmen
sind nicht neu ob sie sich dann aber
auch selbst Antworten geben und sich
selbst neue Antworten geben die wir
nicht mehr verstehen wie sie zu diesen
Antworten gekommen sind das ist
vielleicht neu und manchmal sind sie
auch echt frech also uns hat ein
Roboter ein Chat nämlich auch
ausgetrickst
der capture-test der Beweis dass man
kein Roboter ist um auf eine Webseite zu
gelangen kann KI das austricksen
kann das Online war der Roboter um Hilfe
gab an ein sehbehinderter Mensch zu sein
ganz klar eine Lüge inzwischen haben die
Entwickler dem einen Riegel vorgeschoben
noch mal Miriam Meckel kann man
kontrollieren also
der Roboter der Computer wollte das Ziel
erreichen und hat vorgegeben ein Mensch
zu sein und diesen diese Bilder nicht zu
erkennen kann man wirklich kontrollieren
wie diese Programme lernen und wie diese
Programme funktionieren wir haben doch
die Antwort gerade gehört die Entwickler
haben es unterbunden wir haben die das
gemacht
haben die die Maschinen die der Maschine
die Regel vorgeben die Grenzen aufzeigen
selbstverständlich sind wir die die sie
nein wir setzen am Ende Filter nein
sorry wir setzen das das nennt man das
sogenannte Problem was Sie sehen ist ein
System was tatsächlich furchtbar spinnt
was Dinge macht die absolut nicht
salonfähig sind und das sind genau die
besagten Arbeiter z.B in Kenia oder
Bangladesch die jetzt dafür sorgen
dieses offene terrible wenn man so will
zu erziehen aber das System selber ist
voll also es ist intern und ich glaube
das ist einfach die wichtige Qualität
es ist nicht mehr das was man im alten
Sinne programmieren lernt das ist ein
ein Wunderkasten großartig und es ist
nicht letztes Jahr im November erfunden
worden wirklich November ein bisschen
mehr publik gemacht worden aber es ist
so etwa 2017
eben genau die Antworten gegeben die im
Netz beliebt sind die zu viel gelernt
von Menschen
führen also hat sich verhalten wie wir
in den sozialen Netzwerken wenn man so
will ja und das wollte man nicht haben
also hat man es wieder eingestellt das
ist nicht neu da sagen wir achimberg
dass wir aufhören sollten den
Algorithmus zu beschimpfen sondern die
Menschen beschimpfen die ihnen
missbrauchen
weder noch wir müssen nur einfach
verstehen was wir tun genau das ist
entscheidende und das ist was wir jetzt
hier gerade machen wir machen schon
wieder den Fehler und sagen das dann
denkendes System es ist nicht denkend es
weiß nicht was gut was schlecht was was
böse was was gut ist das weiß das System
nicht das ist nichts anderes ganz brutal
zu sagen als neues Interface fürs
Internet das ist sehr viel schlauer und
sehr viel manuell aber es macht nichts
anderes als das was ein Google Search
auch gemacht hat nur mit tausenden von
dem runter das sagt es mir einfach ich
kann mit dem interagieren ich muss
keinen Computer sprechen mehr machen das
ist der Unterschied ist das mal bitte
nicht den Fehler machen das jetzt
wirklich zu einem intelligenten super
Intelligenz zu machen
weil wir wissen das ist eine
unvorhersehbare Zukunft ist in die wir
da schreiten es ist auch wirklich nicht
wie Google es sucht nicht Informationen
über Liebe sind und sehr serviert mir
die mit einer existierenden Quelle auf
die ich klicken kann und das entlang
lesen
es ist einfach nur eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit Vorhersage welches
Wort am besten klingt nach dem Wort das
schon da steht